today I sit down with none other than
Hillary
Clinton killary I'm sorry Hillary
Clinton thank you for doing this
interview I'm I'm happy to be here I
want to start by saying that I'm not
suicidal whether or not that's not funny
it's no secret Hillary a lot of people
must seriously die or take their own
lives after upsetting you am I going to
be okay I think right now it's too soon
to tell great anyway I don't think
anybody knows us about us Hillary but we
have history well you know we have a
very close relationship so yeah we do
you sexy little vixen you and that
little outfit you look like a unright
plantas want to take a bite out of your
ass is our relationship close enough for
us to make out backstage I I I'm not
ready to do that anywhere so don't take
it personally please okay fine I won't
moving on your husband Bill Clinton AKA
slick Willie he flew to Epstein's Island
over 26 times was he in fact sleeping
with underage girls it really comes down
to what your gut is telling you my gut
tells me yes and that he basically got
away with it Yi Hillary I love when we
finish each other's sentences next
question there are a lot of rumors
circulating that Michelle Obama is
trans I'm sorry I'm sorry H you mind
thanks for the vault by the
way okay a lot of rumors about Michelle
Obama being trans do you know if
actually is and actually went through
with the
surgery well I can't say that because I
was there what you were there come on
Hill you could tell me it's
inappropriate for me to comment on it
but I would just refer you back to what
I was just saying I think that it will
take careful planning to make the
transition which is what President Obama
is trying to do
now what the hell did you do to my fault
I told you I'm not
suicidal you're a crazy
[Music]
thank you very
much